Winston groom author of a storm in
Flanders why did you get interested in
World War one well I think war is always
sort of interested in me a lot of
reasons in this particular case my
grandfather was in World War one went
over did not fight in Flanders fought
with the Americans who mostly fought in
France well about 15 or 16 years old I
remember having a luncheon a Sunday
dinner they call it at my grandparents
house and I was looking through the
bookshelves and found this little en
paperback book which was a Michelin
Guide to the battlefields of eep and
Flanders and my grandfather had gone
over back in the 1920s just to revisit
and had bought these little mission
gadget emission people put out really
stunning historical surveys of the war I
imagine to get people to burn up more
tire rubber for the Michelin rubber tire
company and I began to look at this
thing and thought what kind of
destruction is this I was raised on
World War two my father's in World War
two but I looked at the pictures both
aerial photographs and ground those red
and it looked like Hiroshima and it
occurred to me we've never really were
taught about war will one other than
America One World War one for everybody
and so it after that I begin just to
read a little bit and then I read more
and more and more out of interest not
out of any desired 15 or 16 years over
white a book about it but there came a
point a few years ago and I thought you
know this story hasn't been told
and it was a combination of a number of
things as I think I alluded to the
introduction that I wrote that I had
been in a war myself over in Vietnam I
don't know how these people said that I
don't think I could have gotten my men
to stand that kind of horrible warfare
well on me at four years of nothing but
killing day in and day out remotely the
war that I fought sure you'd have a
fight every once in a while and most of
the time you were doing something else
this thing was four years of constant
Florida what years for world war one
nineteen fourteen to nineteen eighteen
and what years did you write about
1914-1918 let's just take a look at the
cover of your book here and and define
some of these things first of all how do
you pronounce this right here in French
that is pronounced in Flemish eep I like
to say if somebody stuck you in the
bottom of the hatpin what would you say
but they pronounce that on the maps
these days the Belgians have called it
they've Reese pelled it I peor es but
that still pronounced eep how about this
photograph on the cover what is this
that is well I had been arguing my
publisher with that I didn't like that
picture I tell him it looked like a man
being rolled in a garbage dump but they
wanted a photograph and that is a man
removing the what they call the identity
tags which is similar to a dog tags from
a dead man at the Battle of
Passchendaele which was the final big
battle of eath in Flanders slanders is
located where located in in weston
belgium northwestern belgium's here's a
map on the right on the inside of your
book this is the North Sea up here and
the English Channel this would be France
and I outlined the state of Belgium
being right in here
yeah the and the area that you write
about happened we're just well I can't
point at that I don't think but in this
area up here which was the key to the
English Channel ports of Calais and
Dunkirk and belong and i'm not sure i'm
bouncing some of those correctly but if
the Germans had been able to turn that
northern flank of the Allies meaning the
British in the French and secured those
ports there's a question among
historians because nobody ever notices
always what if stuff but if they'd
secure those ports been able to not only
deny them to the British because that's
obviously the supply route across the
channel but to build submarine bases on
those ports conceivably they could have
won the war because also that they would
have turned the flank and been able to
come down the English Channel and get
behind the British and French armies it
was fighting in France so it's very
crucial how many people died in World
War one well about 9 million nobody
really knows anything but the nine to 10
million military people which is an
enormous number and the civilians would
probably about that many for more
civilians died in World War two because
of the bombing on both sides I mean we
know we blew up arrochar menahga sake
and so forth and the Germans murdered
like many people but the number of
military casuals as a military war world
one was extraordinary I mean on Megan
fighting men died and if you I used to
have the math but if you did it by day
how many soldiers sailors Marines so
forth we killed divided into but you
know day by day 24 years it was a lot of
people
what was the war about and when did the
United States get in it well it was
really about and this is so
controversial to be here for a week but
my short version is Germany wish to
expand Germany at this point in the
early part of the century and especially
1912-13 beginning 1914 at an enormously
powerful army and with her ally Austria
Germany sought to expand itself they
they were having what basically what
Hitler said to and say well we'll leave
it so there one more more land they
didn't do it as a verte as overtly if
Hitler did he was quite an evil man i
think the Kaiser of Germany at that
point of the Emperor the king didn't
wish to war but he was ready to fight it
if it was coming and Kostas tinderbox
down in the Balkans in Sarajevo where a
where many bad things happened A Serbian
man assassinated the heir to the
Austrian throne and this set the whole
thing sort of in motion the Russians
felt that they had some sort of suzerain
II in the Balkans because of the Balkans
and mostly Slavic people the Austrians
felt that they ought to have control of
the Balkans and the whole thing was sort
of like a canoe that just rocked and
rocked and finally everybody fell out of
it in the water and then began fighting
each other very vicious what which
countries are on which side oh goodness
there's so many but the may have been
like the main ones on the the Central
Powers said which was the German side he
had obviously Germany austria-hungary
turkey got into it somewhat later those
are the main palace
then the Allies were France which had a
mutual defense treaty with Russia so you
had France Russia Great Britain got into
it because they had guaranteed the
independence of Belgium which was
neutral and they did that because they
knew that Belgium was right sitting on
the English Channel in the North Sea
that he want anybody else coming in
there so Belgium had a treaty with
England since 1838 I believe if they
would guarantee their pendants Britain
got into it and then the British Empire
which was huge because it's an India and
all of the Caribbean nations had written
controlled they came in Canada Australia
New Zealand the Americans stayed out of
it as long as they felt that they could
I think that the Americans really did
not take sides in this thing until after
the Germans torpedoed the enormous
passage line of the Lusitania and some
hundreds of Americans were killed but
Americans traditionally I think had a
mistrust of England we didn't get in it
because of England you know we had
problems with King George in the
American Revolution and in the war of
1812 the British came over and burned
the capital which is right down here and
the White House and in the Civil War the
British sided at least tacitly with the
Confederacy with the South billing them
great blockade running ships and selling
them arms and so on and also you had in
America at that point these enormous
immigrations of Germans and the Irish
who despising and so the Americans were
not eager to get into this fight they
figured you're
Europe problems but after the Lusitania
and after the introduction by the
Germans of gas warfare I think there was
a decided sway in public opinion and in
the American press Germans were not
behaving properly here and it didn't
take much and then when I after the
Lusitania incident when August in 1915
that's right the Kaiser realized he'd
made a mistake the German Kaiser and he
called off unrestricted submarine
warfare then in 1917 he reinstated and a
number of American ships were sunk
nothing on the scale of Lusitania these
are smaller boats but if Americans were
killed and that was it I mean you can't
if you're going to be a nation in we
call the civilized nations and go around
the sinking indiscriminately any ship
that comes in with in any distance of
international waters I think you can
have to fight America and that's what
got us into how many men did we lose how
many were killed Americans in world war
one about 50,000 which is a lot of men
but compared to what the English into
French and the Germans and the other
power that is almost Minh desk you'll
it's horrible to say it but we lost
fifty thousand or more in Vietnam and we
think of this as a huge figure we have a
big memorial right down the road here in
Washington for those 50,000 I don't
think there's a world war one memorial I
don't believe there is and they're just
the only building a world war two
memorial but the just as a an example in
this little corner of Belgium Flanders
I'm writing about which about size of
Manhattan Island there are about 200 and
eighty or ninety thousand British alone
buried there are their markers on the
grave because I know you talked about
the spirits it's one of the biggest
graveyards in the world they're markers
everywhere but eighty thousand of them
were never found they were simply blown
to bits and there is a wonderful
memorial there at what the color menin
gate which was the gate they old
medieval y8 that the Town of East had to
go to get out of peep and go to the town
of Menon which was to the east and that
is the well you can call it a yate and
those they do in the war of the simply
blown apart but that's where most of the
English soldiers marched through to get
to the battlefield and after the war
they restored this gate and all of its
splendor and there are fifty thousand
names of those British soldiers who are
missing carved inside and burnished with
gold and the interesting was if they
began to do this just after the war
ended a couple of years later the
British War Graves Commission determined
that there were another 30,000 but his
soldiers missing and they couldn't be
because the memorial was already in
progress being built it wasn't a way to
put their name so they put them in tyne
cot cemetery which is about four miles
down the road five mile down the road
you could imagine the horror of that
conflict where you had 80,000 men he was
simply blown to bits they couldn't find
enough of them to put into a grave have
you been to the battlefield yes long
time ago I didn't go back for this book
because so much of it now is like under
in the States or something I mean it's
it in a way like a lot of the our Civil
War battlefields here in America
and you know but all countries expanded
their shopping balls with this is and
that's what I've seen enough where's the
accent from my accent yes oh boy you
know I was born wait here your field
hospital in washington DC my father was
in the Adjutant General's Department
he's a lawyer during the Second World
War and he was at pentagon and I came
along and said i was born in washington
but my family has lived in Mobile
Alabama for many many years and then I
moved back to Washington as a reporter
for the Washington star the old paper
here and then I moved from New York's
and I probably got the most bastardized
accent for anybody I remember when
Forrest Gump that they were it was in
production and I got a call from a woman
who was the voice coach for tom hanks
and she said we would like to
tape-record you your voice because you
obviously have the voice of forest gap I
said that's ridiculous I've got nope I
mean I got attacks that are where it's
from I put them on to a friend of mine
do I in my ear mind thought that sounded
like Porsche Cup and they indeed
recorded him and now every day I mean
every two or three years they call him
up and we'd like to record you again for
something else that drives me crazy what
book is this for you what what numbered
look how many books have you written
maybe 12 how many of them are novels
most of them done 12 other than four or
five history or biography thought of
books but I I picture myself as a
novelist but what I've discovered in my
advancing age is that when you don't
have a really good idea for a novel
going to something else and I love
history I love it just as it
it's fun of me is like golf or tennis
and you can really get into it I just
let say they were waiting and suddenly
the material begins to accumulate behind
you in bookshelves and files and so
forth and that the read and you go when
you cross-reference something and it's a
constant influx of ideas whereas I think
in novel writing is more difficult on
some sort of intellectual plain meaning
i can only write novels like two hours
of data they're very intense the phone
doesn't rang I mean I take note you know
I just say like this is my time but
after two hours you get tired history is
a constant job of getting the the
history by getting the story was getting
the material in what year did you write
Forrest Gump and where were you when you
wrote it I wrote Forrest Gump in about
six weeks in 1986 and i was living in
new york but i had come for the winter
to point clear alabama of where which is
a summer resort across from Mobile Bay
where I grew up and I had lunch with my
dad who was quite old it was in his 80s
an old retired lawyer and he began he
reminisce about growing up in
turn-of-the-century Mobile Alabama on
his hot dusty streets and there was a
young man who was [ __ ] probably a
child and the other kids would tease him
and chase him in those sticks at him and
so on and one day this young man's
mother bought a piano and began to teach
him how to play it play it in within a
week he mastered the piano and I
remember going back that even thing ad
and maybe a scene somewhere I recognized
what it was I'd seen 60 minutes they had
a show on idiot savant and
by that night I had written the first
ten pages of Forrest Gump I had the
voice I had the size of the character I
had him ever wherever I wanted I just
went through it no notes no net no
nothing and what did it did it change
your life well I I've been able to
upgrade my brand of toilet paper I mean
it was at a big deal for you at the time
it came it was published which was an 86
87 I can't remember precisely it did
tolerable as books go I think it's sold
twenty-five thirty thousand copies the
movies bought it before it was published
it was Warner Brothers at that point and
it languished is if these projects will
do and from time to time I would get a
call from the producers and they said oh
this is so director would like to do it
now and doesn't such actor would like to
do it and because if movie people love
to talk about access and that they were
talking about Dustin Hoffman Al Pacino
who wonderful actors but both small it
was the you know the jump carrots in the
book is six foot six and ones 100 yards
and 10 flat big guy and finally i just
thought i would say well but i was
writing the scripts at that point they
would say well write it for out of the
guy the fonts the man henry winkler he
wanted to play fit I see some well why
don't we just write it and see if you
find an actor who played us play this
well it hit languished in it languished
in all of a sudden one day they tell us
that Tom Hanks didn't do it and at that
point it had moved Paramount Pictures
and I'm damned they just made it without
made it and now when you write a book
like this on World War one does that
name Winston groom from the forest gump
experience sell a book I I doubt it I
mean I think it does because my name is
sort of familiar vaguely but it is not a
household word it ever once a while I
pick up a new york-bound crossword
puzzle and there I am but it's not like
John Grisham or Clancy or you know the
world famous writers and I one of the
amusing things just after forest got the
movie came out that I was going around
signing books at at this point the book
was I don't know half a million copies I
don't worry I would I was out in Los
Angeles and the same publisher Rove
Atlantic had just published shrouds of
glory which was my little history of the
Western campaigns in the Civil War and
they were paying a bill out there for me
to go to the bookstores around Stanford
and various places and here i would go
to the bookstore and arrive in a
limousine paid for by grove atlantic and
sit down to sign my book tribes of glory
and all these people were lined up
around the block and I leafless with me
to sign Forrest Gump books so I called a
potion I said look I think what we ought
to do here is to say that if you want me
to sign the forest gump book then you
have to buy shrouds of glory I thought
that's pretty small until I realized I
hate signing books I just doubled my
work and I would sit there for sometimes
four and five hours to try to get
through this wrong who really came there
for voice young lady committed by civil
war which is fair enough i mean i don't
i don't like these books to be a big
bestseller I've been fun to be best
seller these are done in a much more
tight spectrum meaning the certain
people who like these kinds of books and
they seem to appreciate them and I
appreciate their appreciation back to
this book this picture seemed to me to
represent right here
what you write about explain what I'm
really well buddy the problem in
Flanders and it was not just limited to
Flanders but the fighting in in that
part of Belgium's was basically fighting
in mud the subsoil in Belgian Flanders
is a very thick blue clay and it doesn't
drain and that's about two feet down and
so when it rains the water simply stays
they released fellas i havenít dig
trenches because of all this horrible
artillery fires going back and forth and
the trenches simply didn't drain that
mean they tried to pump them but the
pumping equipment is very primitive as
you can imagine in 1914-1918 and so most
of the time these guys simply waited
around and water up to their knees and
all sorts of horrible repercussion came
from that such as trench foot which is
now when I was in the Army called an
immersion foot but it simply watched the
feet and then of course we got all that
water you get dead people you're dead
animals very bad infections and diseases
resulted from simply having to stand in
water mostly for battles you write about
ivy yes there were four main battles but
the fighting there was really constant
for four years before you every day what
they call wastage that was the word that
the British Army used meaning the
casualties that occur every day without
there being a major engagement going on
the wastage was anywhere from one to two
thousand men a day in Belgian blenders
every day 365 days a year for years just
the wastage I thought it might be useful
on page 202 you have a long paragraph
that paints a picture I don't know if
you wonder if you want to read i'll give
it to you too
give us some sense of what you found
it's this paragraph right here you need
glasses or can you do that well I didn't
bring them a little I'd be glad to read
if it's but I excited some important the
audience can hear yes the details okay
into one of these holes crawled
lieutenant Alfred J Angel of London
battalion the royal fusiliers most of
his men were teenagers new conscripts
and drafts from the great city for many
it was their first battle the ground
they occupied was he reported lieutenant
angel reported was almost beyond
description the stench was horrible for
the bodies were not corpses in the
normal sense with all the shell fire and
bond Boardman's they'd been continually
disturbed in the whole place is a mess
of Filth and slime and bones and
decomposing decomposing pieces of flesh
as lieutenant Ames will crawl among
these charl pits now under constant
artillery fire checking on his men he
came upon a young boy a teenager his
first time in the line sobbing and
crying he was crying for his mother it
was pathetic really he just kept saying
over and over again Oh mom Oh mom I want
my mum's angel tried to reason with him
but to no avail and became concerned
that his behavior would panic the other
troops finally he slapped him in the
face hard as I could this produced the
desired effect and one of lieutenant
angels corporals said I think I can
manage him now sir well he took that boy
in his arms just as if he were a small
child and when I crawled back a little
later to see if all was well they were
both lying there asleep and the Corporal
still had his arms around the boy maude
accoutrements and all at zero hour they
both went over together more of our
interview with Winston groom in just a
moment mr. grooms examination of
germany's invasion of France through
Belgium is only one of me
early 80 stories taken from the past 15
years of book notes TV interviews found
now in book notes on American character
people politics and conflict in American
history it's available in bookstores and
online and out back to our book notes
interview with Winston groom and how did
you find all this all the details on the
grime and the stench and the death and
oh there's an enormous amount of it in
so many places in people's Diaries in
the letters you can actually find a
great deal of it over the Internet their
whole world war two I mean world war one
site well what do you say to sit there's
on trenches on the way prejudice on the
web really will lead you to practically
any place that is it's a terrific place
to start trenches trenches on the web
and it's a British site and but from
there they will give you links to this
and that the other but I you know you
start off like anything else I started
off aside from my original research
which was just years of accumulating
book here but then by getting the
official history which was written by a
general Edmonds who was that he was all
over the place but he was a brigadier
general and he was assigned by the clown
to write the official history it took
him years they take a look after World
War 2 is finished to finally get it as
many but i think it's i can't members
may be 18 volumes each one some inches
thick and that's really your your
reference point even though there have
been a lot of quibbles with edmunds and
if his version of it
you know his story after the war ended
then what I call the war the books began
as well they shouldn't have done this
they should have done that they should
have done this and so on then you branch
out and there are a number of bookstores
in England that just specialize in world
war one material I mean little monograph
that nobody ever heard of and that's all
things so that's that's really I mean it
just like any other history I didn't try
to do definitive history of World War
one or for that matter of people there
probably a hundred books just on this
battle most of them known in England or
France but not here so what did you do
that you was going to be different well
what I tried to do was using the
fighting in Flanders which is so well
known because of the poem in Flanders
Fields I i tried to use that as a
centerpiece i call it kind of a
Christmas tree effect no that's the the
trunk of the Christmas tree and then you
hang the ornaments on it to describe not
only this battle but to describe it in
the sense of the war is the holes I go
off occasionally on what you might call
a tangent to say well listen what's
going because you can't understand a war
if he just wait about one battle that
you have to mention we're done in
Gallipoli and the sum and I did it for
Americans the English are extremely
well-versed World War One obviously the
whole generation of their men folk a
buried there in France and cleanses the
French ort I think there was some
fantastic figure about the number of
books and other materials in the French
archives on world war one it was like it
was three miles of it or something just
you know look at the book and
paper after paper the Germans don't have
a whole lot and a lot of what they did
have was destroyed in World War two
about bombings on how many men did the
trench lose in World War one the French
French I think about a million and a
half I may have that failure in the book
the British lost about 900,000 French
lost more and a lot of them were lost in
the first three weeks of the war because
they stop the Germans the Germans were
right outside of Paris looking to the
Eiffel Tower and they can actually see
the Eiffel Tower sure and the the French
stopped them at the Battle of the Marne
the British at that point were
relatively small army of about 80 to a
hundred thousand men they were sending
more every weeks I would there's no way
to put a real number on him but the
French had millions in the Germans had
millions how many the Germans lose i
believe about two million somewhere
there is a apologizing else on wasn't
catching up with me but i think it was
about to me to something that all those
things in there at some point and not
nobody really knows where was World War
one fought I mean your time here about
Belgium and also what was thought all
over the world but primarily it was
fought on the Western Front which ran
from the French border with Switzerland
all the way 480 miles north to eat in
the North Sea that was the Western Front
then there was the eastern front with
the dirt with the Germans fighting the
Russians and that ran all the way almost
along the entire Russian border then it
was fought in North Africa the same as
it was for North African World War two
it was fought on the high seas
everywhere sport in Africa itself in
these strange little German colonies and
French colonies and British colonies and
darkest Africa
and the combatants would locate one
tribe or another to fight with them and
there was one very pitiful African tribe
called bastards and they fought against
the Germans very very handily it was
fought in the Pacific Ocean Japan was
our ally with one of the allies and even
though Japan did not fight in any
significant way we'll one when it was
over the Treaty of Versailles gave them
as reward a number of german-owned
islands in the Pacific the marshals the
Bismarck and i believe the parts of the
Caroline's and he became Japanese
mandates from which the Japanese in
World War two caused us a great little
trouble but if we had to go take them
back you mentioned in Flanders Fields a
poem written by Major John McCrae is
that right the Canadian good it's 43
years old I've got it here I can read a
little bit of it just two people haven't
heard it why was it written well in a
gym I think it was a major at that point
McCoy was a physician with the Canadian
Army and he was in Flanders and one of
his good friends who was a young
lieutenant I was blown to bits one day
by an artillery shell and they had to
sort of gather him up and they put him
in a bag of something in some way to
resemble a human form and McCrae
conducted the burial services and
afterwards went and sat on the stoop or
whatever you call it of his ambulance
very depressed and and the people who
were there that was that their whole
books office just on the poem in
Flanders field but Cray SAT there and it
was recorded it walk from wheeling in
the sky the poppies were growing in
Flanders for you
and he penned this poem in I don't have
an hour to every note nobody really
knows how long but but right there on
the very near the battlefield with the
artillery was going off now and didn't
know what to do with it showed it around
a little bit showed it to several
British magazines was turned down and
finally almost a year later a seven or
eight months later punch which is the
British satirical humor magazine
published it and it became emblematic
almost of the war it was a great
rallying cry to take up a quarrel with
the foes this remarkable piece of poetry
I wrote poetry in those days nobody much
waits for any more this was December the
eighth nineteen fifteen yeah first
stanzas in Flanders Fields the poppies
blow between the crosses row on row that
mark our place and in the sky the larks
still bravely singing fly scarce heard
amid the guns below you have other poems
in here in in the book what was when you
go back to the World War 1 N and E pin
these four battles what what would
characterize them I mean you even as you
said earlier you get into the Germans
using gas but what there was a million
soldiers in this valley in this area or
more it depended from time to time there
were more because you have to account
the support troops and reserve troops
and so on they were in the battles
themselves and that each battle was
distinct in of itself there probably
were not more than a hundred thousand
men actually fighting in the given
moment but hand a hand some of it was
very much Han Han it's in the beginning
especially because there weren't have
trenches there was no Bob wire and these
people were fighting over territory
fighting the woods they were fighting
the fields he was fighting everywhere
then sometimes it was very much Hannah
Hannah later it became less of that it
became more of an artillery battle
meaning that the notion was simply to
have the artillery one would hope erase
all vestiges of living life and then the
men would presumably go in and mop up
well that wasn't way it was either
because it soon as Lee or till we stop
the other side we come out of the
whatever hole they were living in and
they would you know shoot you just like
anything else how important were these
battles in the end as to who won the war
well I think he can only assess that by
saying if the British and that there
were French involved as well a teep but
not to the extent that the British were
if the Germans had driven the British
out of the town of peep out of Belgian
Flanders taken the Channel ports I think
the entire war would have had a
different complexion meaning that
depending on the how the Germans used
what they had taken it could have
resulted in a negotiated settlement
earlier than the unconditional surrender
or it could have resulted in an
immediate German victory and I think
historians pretty much agree with that
all the characters you read about they
were involved in eep which one would you
name is number one most interesting
characters characters whether it be a
general or a leader or hey Hague was the
British commander after 1915 sir douglas
Sir Douglas Haig is that everything dude
Hagan Hague Scotch it does he was a
Scotchman and his family was in the
distillery business and hey has been the
probably the most controversial figure
of the entire war which one is in this
photograph here on the bottom here's the
gentleman on the fall right if your
cameras yep looking to somebody else
that's different right here who else is
in that photograph say I believe that is
general jafra on the far left he was the
front commander and I believe that point
care the French president the King of
England is the gentleman here in the
middle and general foix i believe thats
when Frank general is they a french
general that was taken within weeks of
the end of the war they were all smiling
normally you don't clean in smelling
that much smell about so what was so
interesting about Sir Douglas Haig well
actually on the face of it not much it
was said to be very dull person but he's
become so controversial after the war
there as I mentioned earlier that we
came the war of the books and a lot of
people complained bitterly that paying
simply was a butcher and a donkey and he
expended all this life from the battle
of the somme through the battles of
Passchendaele all that was part of the
campaign that he simply didn't care
about human life and he was what they
call a Western I mean he insisted that
the main effort be on the Western Front
as opposed to other areas such as
sending British troops to fight with the
Italian Army which was allied with the
Allies at that time and he get a pretty
bad rap I think I just did this is
opinion i'm not a absolute brick on hey
they've been many many books wouldn't
about hey found him to be an interesting
characters a religious man he got blamed
for that
some historians said general Haig
assumed that he had a divine mission in
winning the war and so forth but my
theory is looking those days a lot of
people religious and if any guy but he's
got a right to pray he's going to be a
picture here of general Haig there on
the left and then Lloyd George the Prime
Minister there on the right if they
would well they that was an enormous
enormously controversial relationship
Lord George did not believe in hey but
he couldn't get rid of him he was a
friend of the king as well if Lord
George who became prime minister about
halfway through the kind the best same
time he became the commanding generals
if Lord George will leave him it would
cause signal to the Germans that the
British didn't like the way the war was
going of political scheming there it
Lord George wanted to do anything to get
the fighting away from the bloodshed and
bloodthirstiness of the Western Front
and hey good not and about the only
thing that you can say about it is that
in the end hey one what everybody else
was left dead on the field hanging the
british ronnie was standing there
whether he was right in this yeah it's a
what if question why did the germans and
why and when did the german jews mustard
gas muster or any kind any kind well
they first day is chlorine gas in 1915
the Germans were actually the largest
manufacturer of chlorine in the world
they had a huge industry and people new
people to about poison gases I mean it
wasn't like some strange secret weapon
but nobody thought of museums is humane
I mean terribly inhumane
they were getting shot out and shelled
out and bombs falling from there and
suddenly get poison the very end breathe
was considered by Barry but the Germans
thought it would give them the
opportunity to break through up there at
eat to get to those Channel ports and so
they release this horrible chlorine gas
in 1915 and it was only the Canadians
who somehow managed by urinating in
their underwear and putting it over
there knows where the ammonia in the
urine would counteract the effect of the
chlorine yes I caylian save the day the
drummer's could have just come pouring
through and accomplished those things
which I suggested that taking the
Channel ports then the Germans used
another kind of gas fires gene gas which
was I read somewhere i remember my
editor and i had a quibble there was
eight times as deadly at chlorine gas
and i had it just said how did I know
it's eight time where was at ten times
ok let's like then that but it was far
more dangerous because if it got in your
lungs I simply ate the logs away and
then mustard gas which was the third yes
they the Germans introduced in 1916 was
probably the nastiest of all because it
simply ate big holes in your skin as
well as destroying your lungs a tissue
I've seen most of the test pictures and
actually did not use one in this book
because I just considered to road test
if people look like leprosy or something
they'll just eat everything what and of
course that soon as the Germans is it
they always begin to use it and it was
it never was a deciding factor in any
battle but it was just another horror or
flight fulness away the British
described it of the war here's some more
pictures that describe what it was like
in World War one what is this is that
that is the final battle of EP which
came to be known as Passchendaele
passion doll one of the almost
unpronounceable word to me bowels in it
but it but Passchendaele was a little
village on a ridge around that Ridge
semi circles eat like an amphitheater
and the Germans of course were occupying
original British wanted it back because
the British were being shelled bite and
this was the actually the battles of
passion doll which lasted about four
months I think came to symbolize all of
the horror and the suffering of the
entire first world war it was fought in
mud sometimes waist-deep it began to
rain in the autumn of 1917 and it never
stops it doesn't stop raining in that
part of the world Holland at four of
northern building which is wayne's all
the time sometimes it's going to big
huge rain sometimes a drizzle lame they
love the drizzling but the ground of
course filled up with water in the men
the British attack had to cross this
slop that had been torn up by at this
point in that battle alone probably four
to five million artillery shells each of
which creates a crater of depending on
the size of the shell of some great
dimensions and its latest filled up with
water and equators were filled up with
dead Germans and Clay's were filled up
with blood in these fellows simply had
to cross this ground maybe 200 yards at
a time maybe half a mile of the time but
they had simply wade through this slop
this picture of a German was that your
idea I found that picture fascinating
yes
the expression on the fellows face shows
sort of incredible determination
defiance defeat all at once and to me it
sort of symbolized the men of both sides
if you look at both sides you can find a
good picture of a British soldier
somewhere and the German so that these
guys they didn't really know what they
were fighting about exactly they were
told to go and do it what's this one
this that is a carrot what they call a
carrying party it's a stretcher bearing
party during the Battle of Passchendaele
showing that the landscape of the
battlefield nothing but craters in water
the character normal carrying party was
for men during that last fight in 1917
fashioned only sometimes had to have 16
to 18 men to carry one stretcher case
out of the battle area because of the
struggling and plus there's so much I'll
tell erated inevitably many of the
carrying party would be killed or
wounded you talked about the building of
the trenches how big were these trenches
that they lived in the British soldiers
idea there's some ideal trenches and I
had been there the ideal trench would be
about six or seven feet deep with what
they call firing steps so that the men
could move in the trench without having
a head blown off but when they had to
fight they would step up on this step
ideally the trench would have duckboards
there would be some sort of drains in
the trench then there would be dugouts
in the back side of the trench for the
men to shelter themselves out of the
weather and so on that's the ideal
trench it will be protected by barbed
wire in front and sometimes more than
100 yards of it I mean
under George out and strand at the
strand of strength there would be
sandbags parapets puratos which would be
the back thing with sand bike in eat
that really didn't work well because the
water level was so low I have no the two
feet below the ground he couldn't dig
wooden teeth again we had water so the
only way that they can really construct
what we call it trench would be actually
what I call it a fortification mean they
would have to build up you get two or
three feet and then they have built up
with sandbags and you know bullet will
go through a sandbag sometimes a man can
be minding his business staying there
smoking a cigarette the next thing you
know his head blown off they're very
unsatisfactory in they will find them
more as the war went on concrete was
used big Timbers were use they had some
metal corrugated things like that some
men even woke home for these will penny
packets of flower seeds to plant flowers
in that trench which is the British
loved plant flowers and they became as
homey as you could make them but it was
still a pre rup business there a couple
pictures here that would later be some
value in World War two and not pictures
but people who's in this picture that is
Adolf Hitler who was a young aspiring
painter and that is in you can create
from here but when the war broke out
Hitler was estatic is in the Munich
Plaza Munich and it was actually a
varian but he joined the army and was by
all accounts a fairly good soldier he
rose to the rank of Corporal never hire
one the Iron Cross does he ever neat oh
yes he was at eight
for three of the three of the four
battles he was gassed there in the end
in 1917 and he was there for the great
Christmas truce which becomes sort of a
legendary element of World War one in
1914 beginning of the war they both the
British and the Germans on Christmas Day
simply quit fighting and went out and
met in the middle of no mans land played
soccer and exchange gifts and tobacco
and photographs and so forth until the
command has found out about it and said
I'm not shooting each other here's
another well-known figure was the world
war two this is winston churchill yes
churchill was there here churchill had
been the first lord of the admiralty and
he set in motion the fairly disastrous
british adventurer in turkey at
Gallipoli and afterwards was drummed out
because of that and went to rejoin his
old regiment adeeb and by all accounts
churchill was a wonderful officer he was
his fairly old in front office he was a
major I think he later became a colonel
he was but he was in his mid-40s had not
fought a battle since the Boer War but
was a remarkable figure his motto was
war should always be fought with a
smiling face and he would tell his
officers if you can't smile and grin do
you have another book guy you're working
on I knew I have a couple the one that
I'm working on now is work is something
that happened after it inspired me after
the sep tember the 11th that horror show
I began to think what what Americans
might be interested in is what Americans
can really do when he get mad
and so I chose to take another look at
1942 which is the first year that
America had to fight world war two and
the first half of that year was an
unmitigated disaster Pearl Harbor entire
fleet was sunk the Philippines were lost
the Japanese were bombing Australia had
taken over all of the southwest Pacific
we would the Allies are being beaten in
North Africa by General Rumble and come
midway in that year in the Battle of
Midway Island our Navy sunk practically
destroyed the Japanese fleet and then
the belly wala canal set us back to
where we were going in Americans a
little tougher than some people give it
credit for when you expect having out
year and a half maybe w we're out of
time this is what the book looks like by
Winston groom a storm in Flanders from
World War one thank you very much thank
you a storm in Flanders is published by
Grove Press on the web at Grove atlanta
com Winston grooms examination of
germany's invasion of France through
Belgium is only one of nearly 80 stories
taken from the past 15 years of book
notes TV interviews fell now in book
notes on American character people
politics and conflict in American
history it's available in bookstores and
online here's a look at some upcoming
book fairs and festivals next week
booksellers librarians and publishers
gather in Chicago for the industry trade
show Book Expo America live coverage on
book TV you'll also find biblio files in
california for the inaugural Los Angeles
black book expo and back in Chicago it's
the largest free literary event in the
Midwest the Chicago Tribune printers row
book fair jun 19th the festival awards
takes place in norwalk connecticut with
an emphasis on cultural understanding
through
stay in Connecticut for the week and the
2004 Wesleyan Writers Conference the
20th through the 25th in Middletown and
in July travel uptown in New York City
for the Harlem book fair please let us
know about book fairs and festivals in
your area and we'll add them to our list
email us at book TV at C span org book
TV continues this Memorial Day with
programs on world war two at eight james
horn Fisher chronicles US naval action
off the Philippine island of samar then
at nine former military nurse rosemary
Nidal Greenlee on US army nurses
you
c-span tues memorial